(upbeat music)
Doing good makes you feel good,
but we wanted to make some "Drew-Gooders" feel even better.
Watch this.
Hi, my name it's Alice Bopp
I am from Rio de Janeiro, Brazil,
and I am the owner of Muni's Coffee Joint
in Lindenhurst, New York.
I have always loved coffee.
And I love communicating with people.
With all the situation with the pandemic.
We wanted to do something.
So I got an note board.
That's how we started.
So you come to the coffee shop,
you grab your coffee,
you add it to your bill another coffee,
paying a coffee forward to somebody else
that you don't know.
And you add the post-it on the board,
and another person who comes later on,
is gonna grab that post-it
is gonna use for their own drink.
With a beautiful note from you.
And from there,
we have been from 400,
maybe 500 post-its already.
And we had letters from people from different states.
I have people sending me money.
That board is showing how much you care
and how much you wanna bright up somebody else's life.
It's pretty much love, love, love all the way around.
I think it's gonna be forever there.
Cheering people's lives.
(upbeat music)
Oh my Gosh.
Ooh wow.
Oh my God, it's so soft.
Oh my God, I love it.
So cool.
Oh man, thank you.
This is amazing.
This is so cool.
Thank you Drew for being part of it.
Thank you so much.
To all the "Drew-Gooders" out there.
Thank you.
(upbeat music)